[Musik]
die anhui christian lindner spricht
chinesisch oder besser gesagt er
versucht es klingt vielleicht noch ein
bisschen holprig für unsere kinder
sollte das aber in zukunft kein problem
mehr darstellen zumindest wenn es nach
ihm geht müssten sie alle in der schule
diese sprache lernen
denn das was der fdp chef hat gerade
gesagt hat soll heißen die gesellschaft
und die wirtschaft ändern sich beständig
wir müssen mit den zeiten schritt halten
tja ob die sache mit dem chinesisch nun
sinnvoll ist oder nicht fest steht
chinas bedeutung chinas einfluss chinas
macht nimmt immer weiter zu
bis 2049 will die volksrepublik weltweit
größte industrie nation sein
mit der neuen seidenstraße soll das
gelingen und genau um dieses
milliardenprojekt geht es heute hier bei
phoenix plus herzlich willkommen dazu
meine damen und herren ja wie der antike
karawanen handelsweg gleich namen soll
die neue seidenstraße china mit
zentralasien sowie europa verbinden und
den internationalen handel erleichtern
alle werden davon profitieren verspricht
peking
doch viele länder darunter auch
deutschland bleiben skeptisch ist die
angst vor china berechtigt
china die neue supermacht ein vor kraft
strotzender wirtschaftskrise mit der
größten armee der welt chinas aufstieg
ist eine gigantische erfolgsstory das
bevölkerungsreichste land der erde ist
längst nicht mehr nur die werkbank der
welt für billige massenware
bei modernen technologien und innovation
ist china ganz vorne
die chinesen tragen mittlerweile weit
über 30 prozent zum wachstum der
weltwirtschaft bei die kommunistische
partei mit stabschef china an der spitze
hat das land ökonomisch geöffnet und an
saldiert zugleich die zivilgesellschaft
mit repression und den methoden eines
überwachungsstaates
jetzt setzt china das größte
infrastrukturprojekt der welt geschichte
um die neue seidenstraße
das land investiert in europa afrika und
dem restlichen asien 1000 milliarden
euro in die bereiche güterverkehr
bodenschätze und schlüsselindustrien ein
projekt bei dem jeder mitmachen darf
aber nur zu pekings bedingungen in china
will größte wirtschaftsmacht werden und
darüber möchte ich jetzt gerne hier in
unserem studio sprechen ich begrüße ganz
herzlich frau professorin nele nyse lsi
ist politikwissenschaftlerin und direkt
neben ihr der steht professor markus
taube wirtschaftsexperte ostasien ich
begrüße auch sie hallo die entwicklung
chinas in den letzten jahren die waren
wirklich rasant wie konnte das gelingen
was hat die regierung in peking alles
richtig gemacht wenn man das so
ausdrücken kann nun senat umgesteuert
china hat von imitation eines westlichen
modells umgesteuert in richtung
innovation china möchte innovations-
großmacht werden und setzt mittlerweile
darauf nicht nur das nationale modell
weiter voranzutreiben sondern dieses
auch über wirtschafts korridore mit der
region mit der globalen welt zu
vernetzen und dabei hat man auch europa
stärker in den mittelpunkt gerückt china
hat es geschafft millionen aus der
absoluten armut zu befreien
und dieses modell scheint exportfähig
das heißt china kann im unterschied zu
anderen industrienationen
die welt für sich gewinnen indem ein
modell exportiert wird der nachholende
entwicklung was relativ kostengünstig
erscheinen
und zugleich setzt ihn auch keine
bedingungen für die kooperation mit
china
das heißt wir werden finanzspritzen
bereit gestellt hier werden
lösungsmodelle als paket angeboten
professor habe ich entnehme ihrem nicken
dass ihr der kollegin zustimmen die
chinesen hatten ja lange zeit dieses
image sie kopieren alles was möglich ist
haben sie das denn jetzt überhaupt noch
nötig ja sie habe sie nicht mehr nötig
muss gibt insbesondere auch kaum noch
etwas was sie kopieren können
also china hat wirklich in einem enormen
tempo den den sprung geschafft von einer
der ärmsten volkswirtschaften unter
entwickelten volkswirtschaften der erde
zu zur spitze der technologischen
kapazitäten die wir haben
das ist noch in ganz ganz kleiner rest
übrig wo wir wirklich noch
technologische vorsprung haben und das
zwingt china jetzt auch wirklich sein
wirtschaftsmodell zu ändern auf endogene
auf eigene innovationen zu setzen eigene
kreativität zu mobilisieren und damit
das eigene wirtschaftswachstum
voranzutreiben
das heißt auch über uns dass die
exportorientierung weniger gewichtig
wird china wird immer stärker in sich
selber und als volkswirtschaft
professoren das wird was bedeutet das
denn für uns auch für uns europäer
müssen wir da angst haben nun china hat
den fokus gelegt auf die interne
entwicklung die stärkung des
binnenkonsums das heißt china eröffnet
sich neu
es baut neue sicherungs modelle auf also
ein sicherungssystem ein rentensystem
steuert um in richtung grüne entwicklung
das heißt china ist erst noch mit sich
selbst beschäftigt aber im zuge dieser
selbstbeschäftigung ist auch ein neues
bewusstsein dafür entstanden dass die
entwicklung in anderen weltregionen eine
rückkopplung hat mit dem was in china
geschieht und damit rückt die
europäische politik in den mittelpunkt
der chinesischen planung und
rückkopplungseffekt ist dann auch für
uns dass china aber und sichtbarer wird
china investiert china hat einen neuen
fokus gelegt auch auf osteuropa auch auf
die balkanstaaten china baut
konnektivität aus über die eurasische
landbrücke und insofern rückt uns china
ein stück näher und wir müssen unser
china bild überdenken
professor taube wie sehen sie das müssen
wir angst haben was machen die chinesen
denn so viel besser als wir oder tun wir
das überhaupt
angst ist immer ein ganz ganz schlecht
das motiv für alles was man tut also ich
denke wir brauchen noch wirklichkeit
angst zu haben wir müssen einfach den
realitäten ins auge schauen wie die
realität 1 ist für mich dass unsere
deutsche politik des wandels durch
handels inzwischen gescheitert ist wir
sagen ein endpunkt gelangt china hat
sich eine zeitlang gewandelt in richtung
unseres systems konvergenz und dann hat
es aufgehört
ja und jetzt ist china dabei sich wieder
von uns weg zu entwickeln
in einem system richtung die ist nicht
wirklich gefällt die uns nicht gefallen
kann
und jetzt sehen wir auf der anderen
seite aber eben auch die
bildungsinitiative die neue seidenstraße
und das ist ein bisserl was wie wandel
durch handel nur auf chinesisch und
genau darüber sprechen wir gleich weiter
bevor wir jetzt intensiv in unsere
analyse einsteigen verschaffen wir uns
allen doch noch einmal einen überblick
über chinas prestige projekt one world
one roth ein gürtel eine straße und so
heißt die neue seidenstraße offiziell
die chinesische neue seidenstraße
umfasst den bau von eisenbahnlinien
straßen und see verbindungen nach afrika
und europa eine dieser bahnstrecken
verbindet china über russland mit europa
um dann in deutschland schließlich
duisburg und hamburg zu erreichen
auf dem seeweg geht es von den
chinesischen häfen über colombo in sri
lanka und im kenianischen mombasa weiter
über den suez kanal nach griechenland
und auch nach italien
teil der strategie der regierung in
peking ist es sich in immer mehr häfen
einzukaufen
auch aus diesem grund ist das projekt
neue seidenstraße umstritten kritiker
warnen zudem vor einer abhängigkeit von
china in vielen ländern jedoch sind die
chinesischen investitionen willkommen
frau professorin erzählt was macht
dieses megaprojekt denn so einzigartig
nun die ausmaße ist weltumspannend naja
wenn es gerade gesehen aber tat gesehen
im volumen ist es weitaus größer und
umfassender als der marshallplan
die chinesen würden sich verfahren gegen
diesen vergleich es gibt grundlegende
unterschiede
der masterplan hat damals europa
zusammen geist der chinesische
investitionen sind bilateral
insofern ist es einzigartig weil china
hier mit ganz ganz vielen weltregionen
verhandlungen führen muss und zugleich
immer das große ganze im blick behalten
sollte das heißt sie wären transport
korridore von peking aus gesteuert und
sie werden individuell ausgestaltet
und das besondere daran ist dass eben
keine konditionen daran gekoppelt werden
das heißt formal kann jeder staat dieser
initiative beitreten das ist auch
geschehen
das besondere ist auch dass china
relativ erfolgreich ein positives image
aufbauen konnte entlang der seidenstraße
wir sehen das in anderen weltregionen wo
eher skepsis vorherrscht hat das
mittlerweile bei umfragen in china
deutlich positive abschneiden als die
usa in die verschiedenen länder blicken
wir im weiteren verlauf unserer sendung
professor taube welche bedeutung hat
dieses megaprojekt denn für die
weltwirtschaft grundsätzlich das ist
etwas was die die asian development bank
vor kurzem sehr deutlich aufgezeichnet
fehlt gerade in der welt in roth region
enorm viel an infrastrukturinvestitionen
und diese einfach
infrastrukturinvestitionen werden jetzt
über die bilder nord initiative in
erheblichem maße bereitgestellt und
infrastruktur bedeutet wachstum
es ermöglicht eine intensivierung und
des wirtschaftlichen austausch ist
erleichtert die internationale
arbeitsteilung auch die nationale
arbeitsteilung und schafft von daher
wohl fort das heißt von der grundidee
ist bildern roth eine großartige sache
und ist durchaus angelegt hier wohlfahrt
zu schaffen und armut zu lindern
großartige sache sagt professor taube
wie sehen sie das nicht alle länder oder
nationen werden davon begeistert wie
stehen die usa dazu in diesen acht
vision der chinesin wird ihnen
wahrscheinlich nicht gefallen er ja die
debatte in den usa wird ja in den blick
auf bedrohungsszenarien geführt china
auf dem sprung die usa als
weltwirtschaft abzulösen
china mit regionalen ambitionen und auch
die debatte darüber dass china einen
wert modell explodieren könnte das heißt
wir gerade gehört an die
vergütungsmodelle was win win
kooperation verspricht wohlfahrt für
alle weltweit und das natürlich sehr
attraktiv für ärmere weltregion die usa
sehen sich aber etwas an die wand
gedrängt sie sehen auch dass sich die
handelsbilanz mit china zugunsten chinas
immer weiter verschiebt und zur
stabilisierung der amerikanischen
wirtschaft sind entsprechende maßnahmen
eingeleitet worden
china agiert ähnlich auch china
fokussiert zunächst auf die eigene
wirtschaftsentwicklung und gerade
deshalb hat man diese kampagne gestartet
die welt in roth initiative
die usa sind jemand hier in
handelsstreit und wenn man will auch in
einem währungsstreit der einerseits sehr
harte fakten umfasst andererseits auch
symbolische dimension
beispielsweise ist die idee dass eine
großmacht nur dann großmacht sein kann
wenn sie technologisch die vorher
stellung hat also dann
innovativ ist technologien
weiterentwickeln kann neu generieren
kann
china investiert in den bereich gerade
im bereich der artifiziellen
intelligente künstliche intelligenz und
die usa sehen sich hier in ihrer
symbolischen rolle bedroht auch im
bereich sicherheitspolitik gibt es
ähnliche konflikte und das heißt also
wir sehen auf einer ganz abstrakten
ebene die perzeption in den usa dass
china möglicherweise so schnell wachsen
könnte dass man keine möglichkeit mehr
hat gegen zu steuern
das dürfte den amerikanern nicht
gefallen professor tauber wie steht's
mit russland welche rolle spielt
russland bei diesem projekt mitglied der
initiative allerdings eigentlich eher in
einen rand player
dessen ungeachtet und ich glaube das ist
etwas was was noch nicht richtig erfasst
alles was er in zentralasien sehen wenn
wir sehen große chinesischen aktivitäten
in kasachstan turkmenistan etc
das sind ehemalige gus-staaten das heißt
es kommt aus der alten sowjetunion gut
hier ist der russische einfluss immer
noch stark ich glaube dass wir in der
westlichen wahrnehmung oftmals übersehen
da es russland immer noch stark nimmt
immer noch einfluss und hier ist china
nicht so allmächtig in seinem einfluss
wie wir uns das hier oftmals vorstellen
frau professor lächelt sie haben sie
eben schon mal angesprochen
die angst davor dass china auch
versuchen könnte werte in die weite welt
hinaus zu transportieren denken sie denn
das ist der fall
aktuell muss man dazu sagen dass china
ja kein modell exportiert china betont
immer wieder dass man
entwicklungsoptionen anbietet aber kann
der transformation anderer systeme
vorsieht
langfristig gesehen haben wir aber schon
den fall dass smart city lösungen die
wir in china sehen ausgetestet werden
ausgetestet werden entlang der welt
droht korridore beispielsweise auch in
der karibik diese karibikstaaten haben
kürzlich auch ein bilaterales abkommen
unterzeichnen mit china und für die
ideen eines wiederaufbaus beispielsweise
haiti nach dem erdbeben hat man einen
großen plan masterplan in china designt
der wissenschaftliche ausgearbeitet
wurde der also die ganze stadt vernetzt
und hier ein chinesisches experiment
globalisiert und wenn das in einem
kleinen land gelingt und einem kleinen
inselstaats gelingt dann könnte das sehr
attraktiv werden damit verbunden sind
aber auch technische technologische
normen und werte und auch das problem
oder die herausforderung für europa und
die usa oder die westliche staaten welt
dass ich enorm und werte mitgeliefert
werden die nicht ganz kompatibel sind
mit dem was wir als europäische komitee
bezeichnen würden das schließt auch eine
frage an professor taube noch an
bei den meisten infrastruktur china mit
den unterschiedlichen ländern realisiert
hat der ist ja auch in eine klausel
eingearbeitet sollte es zu
streitigkeiten kommen gilt das
chinesische recht ja das ist korrekt
allerdings sehen wir auch das nicht
erheblich ganz erheblicher teil der
gelder über die rbi verteilt werden und
das folgt dem westlichen reglement das
sind kredite das sind gelder die werden
auch nach weltbank standards vergeben
und so weiter und so fort
überhaupt ist es so dass ein ganz
erheblicher teil der gelder der im
rahmen der bildungsinitiative investiert
wird in dieser region eigentlich aus
westlichen staaten kommt das ist nur in
der öffentlichkeit nicht so bekannt die
westlichen finanzierungsströme sind
ungefähr die öffentlichen sind ungefähr
auf der gleichen höhe wie die
öffentlichen finanzierungsströme aus den
westlichen ländern nur in der
öffentlichen wahrnehmung ist es eine
rein chinesisches projekt und das ist
nicht nicht korrekt deshalb ist es
eigentlich an der zeit dass europa das
der westen hier etwas stärker sich
positioniert und aufzeigt wo selber wo
eigenes geld drin ist das ein wichtiges
thema dem wir gleich noch nachgehen
werden legen jetzt erst einmal weiter
der frage nach wer könnte von pekings
initiative profitieren oder tut ist
bereits länder in zentralasien
vielleicht die ansonsten in der großen
weiten welt politik nicht so die rolle
spielen china investiert zum beispiel in
usbekistan in
der neuen fabrik in santander
seitenstraße wird aus baumwolle feines
garn made in china denn die
herstellungskosten sind dort viel
geringer als in china anerkannt das war
eine metropole der alten seidenstraße wo
die caravan ihre waren tauschten ja die
seide gold und teure gewürze es ist ein
bilderbuch mal in einem land das sich
erst langsam vom autoritären erbe des
ehemaligen präsidenten karimov befreit
ein magischer ort den usb kisten stolz
der welt präsentiert diese bilder
dagegen dürften wir eigentlich gar nicht
sehen
baumwolle ist die mit abstand wichtigste
einnahmequelle die jahre lang stand sie
unter dem verdacht dass sie mit zwangs-
und kinderarbeit geerntet wird bilder
von den feldern sind nach wie vor
verboten
und wer weiß wie genau der chinesische
textilkonzern nachgefragt hat eine
nagelneue fabrik haben sie gebaut wo
obama wolle zu feinem garn wird die
chefs komme aus china
die top modernen maschinen aus
deutschland von herstellern bei denen
sich der chinesische konzern eingekauft
hat nur der rohstoff und die arbeiter
sind aus usbekistan
wir haben hier investiert bei den usb
gestern die kosten für wasser
elektrizität gas und die löhne für die
arbeiter viel niedriger sind als ich
auch die kosten für den rohstoff
baumwolle sind viel geringer
china kauft ein verfahrens teure
hightech aus deutschland billige
arbeitskraft aus usbekistan verspricht
10.000 arbeitsplätze in der zukunft und
bekommt dafür jetzt schon
steuererleichterungen
aber was es mit der baumwolle die
international auf der roten liste steht
wolle ist das usbekistan die ganze
baumwolle kommt aus der umgebung und wo
kaufen sie die baumwolle
vom handelszentrum nur vom staatlichen
handelns zentrum ein preis liegt der
stadt fest und mehr wollen die chinesen
eigentlich auch gar nicht wissen aus dem
garn wird made in china das verschickt
wird zunehmen in aller welt
niemand wird wohl erfahren woher die
baumwolle kann so geht es oft an der
neuen seidenstraße
jeder fragt nicht viel china investiert
es zählt der wert der ware weniger ihre
herkunft
verfolgt china also ausschließlich
eigeninteressen
die volksrepublik ist für afrika
inzwischen der wichtigste handelspartner
das haben die menschen dort die letzten
jahre eher skeptisch gesehen aber
mittlerweile scheint sich das geändert
zu haben denn laut neuesten studien
begrüßen 70 prozent der afrikaner das
engagement der chinesen nicht regierungs
organisationen werfen der regierung in
peking allerdings vor nur an den
bodenschätzen interessiert zu sein nicht
aber an themen wie zum beispiel
umweltschutz menschenrechte oder einer
wirklichen entwicklung des kontinents
meine kollegin caroline hofmann mit
ihrer einschätzung dazu in afrika lassen
sich viele geschäfte machen und da ist
china ganz weit vorn die afrikaner
brauchen straßen eisenbahnen und helfen
und die chinesen bauen sie afrika
dorthin kann man viel technik
exportieren und geld verdienen außerdem
gibt es dort einen immer weiter
wachsenden bedarf an konsumgütern zb
fisch aus chinesischer aquakultur das
praktische für die afrikaner für die
vielen infrastrukturprojekte bringt
china die kredite gleich mit die
kehrseite
viele afrikanische länder sind massiv
bei den chinesen verschuldet die usa
sind gerade anderweitig beschäftigt die
europäer fragen nach den menschenrechten
china tut das nicht und ist auch deshalb
ein willkommener partner
die afrikaner sind gespalten die einen
schätzen die partnerschaft auf augenhöhe
wie sie sagen die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung den fortschritt die anderen
sagen die schulden seien doch nur die
fesseln der neuzeit und china würde
afrika am ende nur ausbeuten china
jedenfalls baut seine aktivitäten weiter
aus den afrikanischen ländern wurden im
vergangenen jahr 60 milliarden us dollar
an krediten und investitionen zugesagt
und in dschibuti hat china seine erste
militärbasis auf dem afrikanischen
kontinent errichtet china will also
bleiben china fragt nicht viel
china investiert das am letzten paar mal
gehört frau professorin ist dass das
erfolgsrezept
nun wir haben auch gehört gerade in
afrika dass china gezwungen sich neu zu
positionieren neu zu engagieren und wir
sehen auch dass china zwar nicht viel
fragt aber im nachhinein fragen stellen
muss um sich der sicherheitslage
anzupassen wir haben gehört von der
basis in dschibuti
diese eröffnet worden als
logistikzentrum nicht als militärbasis
und china ist die letzten jahre mehr in
den content vorgedrungen mit
staatsunternehmen aber auch mit privaten
unternehmen privaten investoren und
sieht sich herausgefordert durch die
veränderten sicherheits konstellationen
auch chinesische stationen im ausland
auch chinesische handelsdelegation
werden opfer von geiselnahmen von
übergriffen von rebellionen das heißt
man beginnt in china fragen zu stellen
fragen lassen muss genau müssen wir uns
wirklich global an dieser
sicherheitsarchitektur der vereinten
nationen beteiligen müssen wir in krisen
reinspringen müssen wir da irgendwo als
friedens akteur tätig werden und wir
sehen ein umdenken
die global wirtschaftsaktivitäten hier
das in afrika führen dazu dass china
auch in sicherheitsfragen sich neu
erfindet und mittlerweile in zwei
missionen auch eigene kampftruppen
sendet hat mali und sudan professor
taube wie sehen sie das es gibt ja
schlimme vorwürfe gegenüber china china
treibt andere länder in die
schuldenfalle
china wird als kredit dargestellt und
die entwicklungsländer als opfer ist das
auch da ihr bild wie ist das nicht so es
gehe ich sehe es noch nicht so natürlich
haben wir hier entwicklungen gesehen wo
er kurze zeit einzelne volkswirtschaften
über kommerzielle kredite aus china
massiv in schuldensituation
hineingekommen sind wir haben aber auch
gesehen dass china in erheblichem maße
schulden erlassen hat das schult zahlung
umstrukturiert worden sind dh der china
im endeffekt durchaus daran interessiert
ist langfristig strukturen aufzubauen
und sich langfristig zu positionieren
das klassische beispiel ist ja die
hafenanlage in sri lanka wo die
hafenanlage für 99 jahre an china
verpachtet worden ist das halte ich für
einen absoluten pr gau seitens der
chinesischen regierung und ich glaube
das wird auch nicht wieder vorkommen
sie kennen alle das dass chinesen archiv
dass man von den westlichen mächten
unterjochten ausgenutzt worden ist vor
150 jahren das waren 99 jährige
pachtverträge nun dreht sich die
geschichte um und china ist der
situation sofort fließen selber 99
jährigen pachtvertrag ab das hat man
gemerkt dass das keinen sinn macht
und ich gehe davon aus das ist einmalig
geschehen ist nie wieder vorkommt
grundsätzlich ich glaube wir
überzeichnen momentan die negative rolle
chinas das negative engagement
da ist eine ganze menge mehr an
positiven impulsen für die
volkswirtschaften und auch mehr
nachhaltigkeit als es in die medien bei
in der regel auf scheint aber ist das
tatsächlich eine zusammenarbeit auf
augenhöhe
die frage der augenhöhe ist auch die
frage mit wem wir sprechen wir haben uns
die daten jetzt sehr genau angeschaut
und was wir natürlich sehen ist die
restlichen gelder die europäischen gäste
die nach regionen fließen nach afrika
sind sehr viel stärker armut lindern
orientiert wirklich
entwicklungspolitische orientiert
während chinesischen gelder tatsächlich
ehren ein business aspekt haben das ist
keine ahnung linderung
dazu kommt dass chinesische gelder in
der regel tatsächlich unterstellt dass
er eben schon dargestellt an die eliten
gerichtet sind da sind keine konditionen
daran aufgehängt sondern hier geht es
darum entscheidungsträger für china
einzunehmen und das macht man indem man
schaut was sind die elektro etwas in die
ziele dieser eliten und das ist nicht
unbedingt die armutsminderung und das
ist die die ebene in der sich die beiden
geldströme unterscheiden die
chinesischen die westlichen ja ja
natürlich dann steht hier das
chinesische modell ist allerdings auch
auf den entwicklungspolitischen frieden
hin orientiert das ist zumindest das
narrativ mit dem china argumentiert dass
durch den handel bietet man optionen der
lokalen entwicklung und durch
entwicklung verhindert man das
ausbrechen von rebellionen und kriegen
insofern hat man natürlich hier zwei
entwicklungspolitischen konzepten
konkurrieren der fall wirklich gleich
wieder sprechen und sagen ja es gibt
also eine eine wertorientierung
europäischer entwicklungs akteure aber
es gibt eben auch ein konzept was der
chinesischen strategie global unterliegt
und das ist nicht nur negativ da ständig
zu es hat aber auch einige haken und
versteckte mysteriösen der könnt ihr
diese haken noch mal weiter ausführen
die sieht es auch aus mit politischer
einflussnahme das ist ja ein thema was
er auch besprechen müssen wir haben das
im bereich der eu-politik gesehen das
wird immer schwieriger eine gemeinsame
haltung der eu zu erzählen in der frage
der china politik das ist allerdings
jetzt keine
folge der seidenstraßen initiative das
hat mir schon früher also immer wieder
war schwierig einstimmig zu entscheiden
eine gemeinsame strategie zu formulieren
die einzelnen staaten haben natürlich
bilaterale verträge auch mit der vr
china abgeschlossen eigenen interessen
die sie verfolgen über die eu im
einzelnen sprechen wir später noch aber
wie sieht es aus mit dem ziel der
chinesen es geht auch darum politische
werte oder den polo politischen einfluss
zu erweitern
das kann ein nebeneffekt sein was wir
erstmal sehen das ein ganz ganz starke
fokussierung auf die wirtschaft erst mal
die fokussierung auf die stabilisierung
der interne entwicklung also der
wirtschaft in china selbst denn das
system stabilisiert sich legitimiert
sich durch output das heißt nur solange
das wirtschaftswachstum einigermaßen
positives und stabil ist lange zeit
sprach man von 8 prozent die benötigt
werden damit das system stabil bleibt
mittlerweile sind wir untergegangen auf
da wird neue negative kreiert sie sagt
die neue normalität das heißt ein grünes
nachhaltiges wachstum das geht eben nur
mit sechs oder sieben prozent
aber eben genau dieses wachstum ist
notwendig damit es keine aufstände gibt
damit wohlfahrt oder wohlstand für alle
generiert werden kann und in zweiter
linie komma politische implikationen
gebe auch für china vielleicht im ersten
schritt gar nicht mitgedacht worden sind
wir drei sprechen gleich weiter zunächst
kommen wir erst mal nach deutschland
genauer gesagt nach duisburg der ruf der
stadt na ja der könnte wohl besser seien
die kassen sind leer die
arbeitslosigkeit ist hoch seit dem
niedergang des bergbaus kämpft die
region mit dem strukturwandel
chinesische investitionen sind da eine
willkommene hilfe
seit fünf jahren endet die neue
seidenstraße in der rheinmetropole rund
30 prozent des gesamten handels per
güterzug zwischen china und europa
werden bereits über den duisburger hafen
abgewickelt
duisburgs zukunft liegt im handel mit
china schon heute zieht diese blaue
lockt fünf mal täglich den chinesischen
zug aus dem container terminal am
duisburger hafen 600 meter lang ist
jeder der züge der über 11.000 kilometer
aus china bis an den rhein rollt es ist
ein angebot das sich eigentlich zwischen
der sehr teuren luftfracht und der sehr
viel günstigeren seefracht da brauchen
sie aber sieben wochen sechs bis sieben
wochen
container von duisburg nach chongqing
transportiert zu haben
und genau in der mitte siedelt sich das
eigentlich an china will den handel mit
europa deutlich ausbauen
dafür finanziert die volksrepublik mit
der neuen seidenstraße einem ehrgeizigen
infrastrukturprojekt ein netz aus häfen
eisenbahnlinien und straßen von asien
bis nach duisburg
hier am endpunkt der seidenstraße werden
die container dann zum weitertransport
verladen
die chinesen versuchen natürlich auch
ihre einflusszonen weiterzuentwickeln
die politik muss dafür sorgen und
insbesondere die europäische union dass
wir gleiche bedingungen haben die kritik
der europäer an chinas mammutprojekt
wächst auch deshalb hat china zur
zweiten internationalen seitenstraßen
konferenz nach peking geladen
vertreter aus über 100 ländern sollen
vom gegenseitigen nutzen überzeugt
werden
für den deutschen wirtschaftsminister
kann das aber nur funktionieren wenn
china auch europäischen unternehmen
einen freieren marktzugang garantiert
wir brauchen ein sogenanntes level
playing field das heißt gleiche rechte
und gleiche möglichkeiten für alle
wir brauchen den abbau von behinderungen
die es heute noch gibt auf dem alten
duisburger thyssenkrupp gelände stehen
bereits heute tausende von containern
und die stadt will weiter profitieren
von chinas investitionsoffensive
professor taube inwieweit hat die pop
band schon davon profitiert oder auch
die ganze region also duisburg ist mit
sicherheit einer der hauptprofiteure
also wir haben nicht nur wie es eben
gerade genannt wurde eine reihe von
chinesischen investitionen haben über
100 chinesische investoren inzwischen
den in duisburg sondern es kommen ja
auch aus deutschland aus europa
investoren in die stadt hinein um dort
ihre logistik geschäft zu betreiben und
das ist ein ganz ganz wichtiger impuls
für die stadt die ja tatsächlich
industriell brüssel aufgrund alles
gelaufen war und das belebt tatsächlich
die die volkswirtschaft vor schafft
arbeitsplätze schafft einkommen schafft
steuereinnahmen und bringt europa wieder
auf die weltweite karte sie glauben gar
nicht wie berühmt und wie kann bekannt
ist in china ist die anzahl der züge aus
china nach duisburg wird immer größer
das haben wir gerade
wie sieht es denn andersherum aus der
also gibt es in beide richtungen gleich
viele das ist ein geschäftsmodell das
natürlich entstanden ist aus der idee
güte aus china nach europa zu
transportieren
über den haben wir haben ungefähr 35
züge pro woche in beide richtungen
insgesamt und wir gehen davon aus dass
wenn zwei volle container nach duisburg
kommen nur einer von denen voll wieder
zurückgeht das heißt hier geht einiges
an container leer zurück und das heißt
sie haben noch potenzial für dieses
geschäftsmodell das heißt aber auch dass
die preise anders sind wir haben über
zirka vier bis 5000 us-dollar pro
container nach westen nach duisburg und
circa 3.000 dollar was der container
kostet nach china also der sehr viel
billiger da ist durchaus noch luft das
kann man bedienen wir sehen dass hier
sehr viel zum beispiel
automobilkomponenten nach china gekauft
wird wir sehen aber auch zum beispiel
schrotte spezialstahl etc die nach china
transportiert und dort weiterverarbeitet
werden
frau professorin das hält der
wirtschaftsminister fordert aber
weiterhin faire wettbewerbsbedingungen
auf beiden seiten wie weit sind davon
noch entfernt und was müsste sich dann
noch eine gute erste punkt ist natürlich
die frage wie weit ist china eine
marktwirtschaft die unseren westlichen
definition volk darüber hat mir lange
nachgedacht man hatte auch damals bei
den beitrittsverhandlungen chinas zur
welthandelsorganisation in aussicht
gestellt dass china dann nach einer
gewissen zeit als marktwirtschaft
anerkannt wird
china hat so zumindest die kritik nicht
alle kriterien erfüllt man redet also
nicht mehr wer diesen
marktwirtschaftsstatus aber genau das
ist der punkt
china hat eine eigene variante des
kapitalismus eine variante des
kapitalismus wo der staat möglichkeiten
hat zu intervenieren die wir in unseren
systemen gar nicht mehr vorsehen
wo wir sagen würden das verzerrt den
wettbewerb auf der anderen seite gibt es
auch von chinesischer seite kritik an
unserem modell beispielsweise auch in
den europäischen entwicklungsmodell und
auch hier wird kritisiert dass der
marktzugang für china nicht immer ganz
frei dann möglich sein
was sagt der wirtschaftsexperte dazu das
ist der fall wir haben einfach zwei
systeme die nicht voll kompatibel sind
wir haben den westen
wettbewerbs basierte marktwirtschaft die
haben wir in china definitiv nicht jene
starke massive staatliche interventionen
in unternehmensentscheidungen
strukturelle ausrichtung der
volkswirtschaft das ist langfristig
nicht kompatibel deshalb plädieren wir
eigentlich für die einrichtung von
mindest schleusen oder adapter
institutionen die einfach
zwischengeschaltet werden müssen
in die wirtschaftsaktivitäten zwischen
china und deutschland und europa wir
haben lange zeit auf sowas verzichtet
weil wir gesagt haben
china ist so klein chinesische
unternehmen sind so schwach da können
wir dieses dieses kleine bisschen an
eine diskriminierung gegen uns körper
absorbieren nahe die zeiten sind vorbei
die deutsche regierung ist ja ziemlich
skeptisch was die neue seidenstraße
angeht die deutsche wirtschaft hingegen
scheint er begeistert zu sein will kann
sich das alles macht auch viel sinn weil
die seitenstraße nicht einfach nur diese
transport korridor ist über den wir
gerade gesprochen haben die container
die ihr hin und her gekarrt werden
sondern die neue seidenstraße schafft
einfach neue industriezonen ein neues
industrielles geflecht und zwar wenn wir
jetzt einfach mal zentralasien hervor
greifen dann haben wir eine ganze reihe
von land lockt countries also länder die
keinen zugang zum meer haben und von
daher in ihrer interaktion mit anderen
staaten mit ihrem ein klick in die
weltwirtschaft massiv behindert sind
jetzt durch diese transport korridor
durch diese massive
infrastrukturinvestitionen stehen neue
möglichkeiten diese diese länder
einzubinden das beispiel was soeben
hatten in dem einspieler von seiner
markant ist ein wunderschönes beispiel
und es zeigt auch sehr schön wie
deutschland sich hier engagieren kann
ist es davon gesprochen worden dass wir
top moderne maschinen aus deutschland ja
darum geht es ja ich meine was machen
wir machen maschinen das ist unser
komparative kostenvorteil
und wenn wir den jetzt nach nach seiner
markant bringen können ist das doch
wunderbar in kooperation mit einem
chinesischen geschäftsmodell was vor ort
fertigt haben wir in deutschland etwas
verschlafen frau professorin das haben
wir uns auch mit dem projekt
seitenstraße zu spät beschäftigt ist
natürlich die frage was sich hinter
diesem projekt seidenstraße wirklich
verbirgt es ist ein großes chinesisches
negativ weil man sogar märchen mit dem
man die frage beantwortet was strebt
china an was ist die große chinesische
strategie und man versucht so wenig die
bedrohungsszenarien die es gibt
auszubremsen und zu sagen hier
präsentieren wir unseren langfristigen
masterplan
so langfristig und so global ist hier
vielleicht gar nicht wieder jetzt auf
den entsprechenden karten erscheinen mag
es gibt möglicherweise die korridore
irgendwann in der zukunft aber es gibt
bislang nur punkte auf der karte die
offiziell dieser initiative zugerechnet
werden wir haben insofern nichts
verschlafen in dem sinne was wir
vielleicht beachten sollten ist dass
china gerade mit blick auf industrie 4.0
versucht eigene strategien zu entwickeln
in dem bereich wirklich extrem
investiert und eben auch versucht zugang
zu bekommen zu europäischen
westeuropäischen der industrie bereichen
die wir bisher eigentlich noch als
unsere schlüsseltechnologie gesehen
haben
und da ist natürlich die frage wie
können wir hier regelwerke erarbeiten
die mit eu regeln konform sind unsere
möglichen nationale interessen auch zu
sichern
die usa haben dort
interventionsmöglichkeiten die bislang
in der eu und in deutschland nicht
verhandelbar sind ja die nicht vorhanden
sind und es heißt hier werden wir in
zukunft und zum neu positionieren
über die position der europäischen union
sprechen wir gleich wie sollte ich
nämlich die eu künftig mit tine wie soll
die eu künftig mit china umgehen ist die
volksrepublik mehr partner oder mehr
rivale so ganz einig ist man sich in den
einzelnen mitgliedstaaten darüber nicht
die zeit der europäischen ebene ist
vorbei
das zumindest betonte frankreichs
präsident micron blick auf chinas
seitenstraßen pläne
es ist ein freundliches lächeln aber ein
lächeln dass das weltweite macht streben
die totale kontrolle über das volk die
verletzung von menschenrechten und
umweltschutz verbirgt chinas präsident
lächelt die initiative der europäer
einfach weg gemeinsam mit europa so
zumindest der plan
chinesischen expansion entgegentreten
nur respekt und erschienen sie
resignieren china ziehen wir wollen
dialog und zusammenarbeit aber wir
erwarten dass china auch unsere
einheiten und unsere werte respektieren
die welle skateboard große worte die
spät kommen möglicherweise zu spät
china ist längst da und die einheit nur
noch ein frommer wunsch
der zuständige minister aber beschwört
europa
das ist ein punkt den wir in der
europäischen union intensiv diskutieren
müssen
das nämlich alle mitgliedsstaaten die
verpflichtung haben das gemeinsame
europäische interesse höher zu stellen
als wirtschaftliche erwartungen
gegenüber anderen ländern weltweit
das ist eine frage des wirtschaftlichen
und politischen überlebens von europa in
rom setzt man voll auf china und bekommt
dafür beifall aus deutschland es ist
völlig normal dass staaten die eben
vielleicht in wirtschaftlich schweren
fahrwasser sind wie italien ja sich
natürlich möglichkeiten suchen wer ihnen
beispielsweise den hafen in triest dem
neubau bezahlt doch bezahlt wird auch
mit abhängigkeit china investiert in
bahnstrecken und häfen um die halbe welt
thailand singapur colombo suez bis
hinein nach europa malta piräus masse
antwerpen rotterdam und aus
wirtschaftlichem invest wird politischer
einfluss beispiel ungarn für den bau
einer bahnstrecke investiert peking über
zwei milliarden euro ist es nur zufall
dass viktor orban bereits eu erklärungen
zum südchinesischen meer verhindert hat
oder griechenland schon vor zehn jahren
hat athen seinen wichtigsten hafen
piräus an china verpachtet und auch
griechenland zeigt in manchen eu gremium
eine auffällige china freundlichkeit
wir waren sicherlich in der
vergangenheit zu blauäugig auch zu naiv
und hab fangen jetzt an zu reagieren ich
bin überhaupt nicht für generelle
ablehnung von chinesischen
direktinvestitionen
aber wenn es eine infrastruktur und vor
allen dingen kritische infrastruktur
geht dann sollten wir eben auf die
europäische karte setzen
knackpunkt nur dass europa diese
ausgaben bisher scheut im gegensatz zu
china und auch beim neuesten projekt dem
ausbau des 5g netzes huawei der
chinesische technologie riese wird
massiv um eine beteiligung und behauptet
dafür sogar man sei unabhängig vom staat
dabei ist weight tief verstrickt in das
überwachungssystem in der provinz geng
yang unterdrückt die zentralregierung
brutal die minderheit der uiguren und
der tec konzern ist offizieller partner
der chinesischen staatssicherheit und
baut dem geheimdienst ein sogenanntes
innovationszentrum noch zögern die
europäer huawei auszubooten doch der
druck ist enorm und so bleibt ein
schales gefühl angesichts der kluft
zwischen worten und taten es wenn es
dabei bleibt
da müssen sich die chinesen über ihre
einflussmöglichkeiten in der eu nicht so
viele gedanken machen war ja dann immer
noch 26 andere da sind an die man sich
halten kann
shipping lächelt für den chinesischen
präsidenten ist das alles nur eine
zwischenstation auf dem weg zurück an
die weltspitze
da wo sich china schon immer sieht seit
jahrhunderten professor taube wie
wichtig ist es in diesem fall dass der
eu mit einer stimme spricht das feld
hier ja bei vielen themen schwer
die ist dass in dieser sache ist es
elementar weil deutschland ist viel zu
klein
nur die eu ich meine wir haben 500
millionen einwohner das ist deutlich
stärker als die usa wie haben die
deutlich stärkere industrielle basis als
die usa ist stark wenn sie sich einmal
tatsächlich dazu beraten könnten mit
einer stimme mit einem interesse zu
reden die chinesen haben es bislang sehr
geschickt vermocht europäische
interessen auszuhebeln
mit einzelstaaten sonderregelung zu
erhalten jetzt aber die 16 +1 initiative
ist china das ist die einst durch 16
osteuropäische staaten manche von denen
eu mitglieder anderer nicht da versucht
man tatsächlich eine ein keil hinein zu
treiben nach europa und das ist kein
freundlicher akt und das wird so
kommunizierten das weiß china auch dass
hier die perzeption in europa sehr sehr
negativ ist zu dieser initiative sehen
sie das ganz genau so dass das mit
absicht gemacht wird ein keil zwischen
der europäer zu treiben und wie
gefährlich ist dann so einen alleingang
von italien also noch zurückgekommen auf
den keil man kann es auch anders
interpretieren man kann auch sehen dass
die überarbeitung der eu strategie
dokumente für zentralasien
da läuft die eurasische landbrücke
anteile seidenstraße durch und die
aktualisierung der balkan strategie
erfolgte nachdem china in diesen beiden
regionen seiner charmeoffensive
gestartet hat das heißt möglicherweise
langfristig betrachtet sind diese
interaktion auch eu befördert oder
zumindest stabilisieren sie die aktuelle
fragmentierten debatten in eine
bestimmte richtung dass wir sagen nur
geschlossenheit kann dazu führen dass
wir mit einer stimme
uns gegenüber anderen großen
wirtschaftsakteuren durchsetzen können
die fragmentierung die schreitet fort
das haben wir gesehen 16 +1 vielleicht
sogar schon 17 +1 vielleicht wenn man
griechenland noch dazu rechnen das ist
also gefährlich auf der einen seite auf
der anderen seite
ist es immer wieder in der phase der
europäischen einigung debatten dazu
gekommen dass wir das bild bag prozesse
hatten möglicherweise gehen wir gestärkt
aus diesem einen spiel beck gerade
hervor
die frage aber natürlich mit osteuropa
wird es langfristig eine orientierung in
richtung osten geben in richtung
russland in richtung zentralasien in
richtung china
ich glaube nicht werden wir uns die
zahlen anschauen das weiß der kollege
sicherlich besser dann ist das nur ein
ganz kleiner bruchteil den china dort
investiert und immer wieder gerät china
auch in konflikten mit dem geltenden
eu-recht also beispielsweise wurde der
bau einer eisenbahn von belgrad nach
budapest piräus gestoppt weil eben dort
auch ein teil des eu binnenmarktes und
damit auch das aki gründet er betroffen
waren
china kritischen zeigt sich der
französische präsident er ist jetzt
nicht vorgeprescht aus welchem grund ist
rationalität
naja warum vergleich zu deutschland ist
frankreich weniger abhängig von china
als deutschland wir sollten nicht von
abhängigkeiten sprechen sind
wirtschaftliche rechnung geführt dass
eine flechtungen das ja also frankreich
hat vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
spielraum als deutschland mit sicherheit
aber ich sehe es einfach auch als ein
wirklich ernst gemeint ist politisches
programm was europa in die zukunft
führen kann und da ist für ein bisschen
führung vielleicht von deutschland
letzten jahren ein bisschen gefehlt und
makro hat dir einfach einen ein neues
kapitel aufgeschlagen was positiv ist
was definitiv positiv ist aber
entscheidend ist wird mit makro das
sollte man betonen makro als jean ping
zu besuch kam hat marco merkel und
juncker eingeladen hat juncker die
hauptrede halten lassen das sind ganz
ganz wichtiges signal gewesen du
besuchst mich hier in frankreich aber
das ist europa was du triffst ganz ganz
wichtiges symbol
abgesehen davon was wir einfach machen
müssen wir hatten schon darüber
gesprochen doch gerade im fall ungarn
was es eben angesprochen ungarn bekommt
viel viel mehr geld aus der europäischen
union als von china das heißt ungarn ist
im endeffekt abhängig von europa nicht
umgekehrt nicht von china und wir haben
auch gesehen dass orban jetzt bei dem
bei den bildern roth gipfel sich doch
im hintergrund gehalten hat was man
früher anders gesehen hat er hat das
bereits angenommen und es hat sich die
die große freundschaft nach china nicht
mehr so nach außen betragen
also wir tun gutes und wir müssen viel
mehr darüber reden
ihre einschätzung zum abschluss unserer
sendung dabei beginne ich einmal mit
ihnen china hat die version 2049 will
man weltweit größte industrienationen
seien übrigens pünktlich zum hundertsten
geburtstag der volksrepublik ja wie
realistisch ist dass dieser chinesische
traum wahr wird in der ich in den
schutzraum ist eigentlich schon wahr
geworden wenn man sich die
kaufkraftparitäten anschaut
allerdings ist die frage wie lange kann
china diesen status stabilisieren und
das ist das große szenario was in china
durchgespielt wird positiv wie negativ
das wird beobachtet wie andere
großmächte aufgestiegen sind und sehr
schnell wieder gefallen sind und die
strategie die wir mit der seitenstraße
sehen ist eine langfristige
stabilisierung strategie also die
strategie eines nachhaltigen grünen
aufstiegs und dann die idee kinder lange
jahre hunderte möglicherweise an der
spitze zu halten
im konzert mit anderen großmächten
kinder schritt nicht nach der alleinigen
führung das ist viel zu teuer
da werden ressourcen reingesteckt jene
aktuell nicht frei verfügbar hat und
sofern geht es darum langfristig
multipolar zu agieren zu interagieren
mit anderen weltregionen professor
tauber sehen sie das genauso wird diese
strategie die langfristige strategie
aufgehen
ich glaube dass china tatsächlich mitte
dieses jahrhunderts die entscheidende
wirtschaftsmacht der welt sein wird
sie wird die usa geholt haben ich glaube
auch dass china in technologischer
hinsicht noch weiter nach oben steigen
wird ob sie die usa überholen müssen sei
dahingestellt es kommt im endeffekt
immer darauf an die volkswirtschaft ist
immer nur ein teil des
gesamtgesellschaftlichen systems das
heißt was wird in den nächsten 30 jahren
passieren wenn wenn die chinesische
bevölkerung wird nicht materiell satt
ist
wenn neue politischen interessen
auftauchen wenn das social scoring
system sich etabliert hat wenn wenn ganz
neue sozialpolitische strukturen sich
entwickeln es ist es wäre
kaffeesatzleserei aber aus der
ökonomischen perspektive heraus hat
china alles zeug um mitte des
jahrhunderts die führende nation die
vier und acht zu sein
optimal zu dem zeitpunkt dann auch
stabil sein wird das ist die ganz ganz
große frage
vielen dank ihnen beiden ganz herzlich
für ihre einschätzung hier bei uns im
phoenix studio ja und ich bedanke mich
natürlich auch bei ihnen meine damen und
herren für ihr interesse und ich hoffe
wir konnten ihnen einen informativen
einblick geben in chinas macht visionen
und wie andere länder darauf reagieren
bis bald und gute unterhaltung in
unserem weiteren programm